So, you know I think a lot
about the transformative power
of cinema.
The Interpersonal
impact of a great film.
A great film can awaken
us to our inner genies.
A great film can imprint
itself in our consciousness
and transform us from within.
The French new wave
filmmaker, Godard,
said that cinema was
truth 24 times per second.
Gene Youngblood expanded on this
in his book, "Expanded Cinema."
He says cinema reflects
mankind's historical urge
to manifest his consciousness,
his interiority outside
of his mind, in
front of his eyes.
Cinema is a mirror we
hold up to ourselves
that reveals us to ourselves.
It's a dream sharing
technology that
allows us to visit the space
of truth, of archetype,
of myth, of legend.
It's the magical borderland.
It's the story world in
which we lose ourselves,
and we find ourselves.
The book "Cartographic
Cinema" goes even farther.
It says that cinema is
cartography for the mind.
Cinema is a map for
consciousness offering us
orientation in this
imaginal realm of dream.
And of course, with such power
comes great responsibility.
Cinema as a tool, as a technique
for such cathartic illumination
means that filmmakers
have a responsibility
to craft work that thrusts the
human spirit into the numinous.
We need to expand the
consciousness of society.
As filmmakers, as
craftsmen of the lens,
this is our responsibility.
That's what I think.